momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge iniciamos
en ucrania porque continúan los malos
datos para la economía de este país así
es ahora el dato lo dio el banco mundial
y prevé que esa economía se va a
contraer este año al menos en 45 por
ciento mientras que para rusia la caída
estimada es del 11 por ciento según mi
prestamista el banco adelantó que para
los países de mercados emergentes y en
desarrollo de europa y asia central
serán los más afectados la última
actualización del banco mundial prevé
que la economía de la región se
contraiga un 4,1 por ciento este año
frente a la previsión de crecimiento que
habían dado de 3% anterior a la guerra
esto por el impacto de la guerra y los
efectos de la pandemia
el banco mundial aclaró que los únicos
países cuyas economías se van a contraer
son ucrania rusia de la ruth moldavia
kirguistán y tayikistán la guerra está
calando los mercados financieros y de
materias primas así como en los vínculos
comerciales y la confianza empresarial
rusia y ucrania representan alrededor
del 40 por ciento de la importa de trigo
de la región y cerca del 75 por ciento o
más en asia central y el cáucaso sur
ahora seguimos con las previsiones de
crecimiento del de la ocde
esta es la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
que ve signos de ralentización en toda
la economía de europa según sus
indicadores compuestos avanzados
presentados este lunes economistas como
economías perdón como alemania francia
italia españa o reino unido van a frenar
el crecimiento como efecto de la guerra
mientras que eeuu japón o canadá la
tendencia sigue siendo estable estos
indicadores compuestos avanzados de
marzo son estadísticas que señalan
fluctuaciones en el ciclo económico con
entre 6 y 9 meses de anticipación y
prevén ahora una baja en los países del
viejo continente para los países de
américa latina' miembros de la ocde lo
más sobresaliente es la caída de chile
con un bajón de 48 centésimas en marzo
mientras que los países fuera de la ocde
como brasil muestran un descenso
considerable también en marzo jorge
enjoy lanka se acentúa la crisis
económica ahí llevan semanas de
protestas por apagones y una grave
escasez de alimentos y combustibles así
como otros productos la comunidad
empresarial de siri lanka que financió
la campaña electoral el actual
presidente parece distanciarse ahora del
mismo más de 22 organizaciones
empresariales e industriales piden un
cambio de gobierno aseguran que las
pérdidas diarias habían alcanzado unos
50 millones de dólares sólo por las
casas de combustible el país se
encuentra en una en conversaciones con
la vecina india para asegurar otra línea
de crédito de combustible de 500
millones de dólares que permita hacer
frente a la escasez de suministros en un
intento desesperado para contener la
caída de la rupia la moneda local el
banco central aplicó el viernes la mayor
subida de tipos de interés de la
historia de ese país de 700 puntos
básicos antes también el gobierno
recortó varios impuestos para rescatar
la economía ahora la nación se prepara
para una ronda de negociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional en busca
de un plan de rescate de tres mil
millones de dólares varios expertos
apuntan a que esta crisis lleva años
desarrollándose y lo acuñan a una mala
gestión económica que sumada a varios
desastres natural la crisis política
hacia la pandemia del cob y 19 derivaron
en la actual crisis económica porque
este martes se dará a conocer el dato de
inflación de eeuu y según una encuesta
de bloomberg se espera que el dato
interanual toque los 84 por ciento a
eeuu en el último dato de febrero se
ubicó en 79 por ciento interanual muy
por encima de la meta del banco central
que era del 2% para este año de
cumplirse con esta proyección de
bloomberg se ubicaría sobre el 8% sería
el aumento más alto desde 1982 y
reflejaría el golpe del aumento de los
precios de la energía tras la invasión
de ucrania los elevados precios de los
productos del último año se deben en
gran parte al aumento en sectores como
la automotriz y los artículos del hogar
y si bien es cierto el costo de los
vehículos usados ya comenzaron a acceder
el costo de alquiler de vivienda ha
comenzado a subir el mes pasado la
reserva federal se mostró abierta a un
aumento más agresivo de los tipos de
interés para frenar la inflación momento
de conocer los indicadores iniciamos en
wall street que cerró en rojo y con los
impresores temerosos por la inflación y
las posibles consecuencias de un aumento
de los tipos de interés
la reserva federal de eeuu en europa las
acciones europeas cayeron ya que el
aumento de los rendimientos de los bonos
afectó las acciones de tecnologías y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
retrocedió arrastrada por el mercado
internacional y por las perspectivas de
las medidas que tomará el banco central
de ese país para frenar también la
inflación 'jorge muchas gracias por la
información económica de ustedes
televidentes también muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]